I see like probably 20 cop cars come
flying by him like damn somebody robbed
a bank my dumb ass and then I see a
military like Hummer come by like oh
[ __ ] and I walked down I see a cop we go
what's going on I'll get out of here for
you the protest about to start man music
and we're gonna shut this area down you
won't be able to get in or out for a few
hours and you're like well they have
funnel cake together
this is Hill remember this one y'all got
some ratchet in a man and my ratchet
hoes you got to get ratchet brother
gotta get read are you you got to take
one of your arms off right don't be a
little [ __ ] we need to shoot one of
your arms I'll rip your arms off put
them on [ __ ] mouth I'll take your
eyes out and put them in my nutsack
music my ratchet Dave alright his team
all ratchet you gonna take somebody's
ass what a sword nah man again oh damn
first team all ratty damn I might get a
brassiere tattooed on my ass nipple
popping at the top that's not a bad idea
at all yeah man Boosie was in here man
bellows yeah it was wild brah you call
uh I would say he's tall in spirit you
know okay but on the outside he's not
that tall
yeah he probably 30 feet long if you
cracked him open he from Louisiana yeah
he's wild man he's one of a kind that's
him right there
oh he sure he's real the legend brah oh
yeah somebody put this busi in kibou see
[Laughter]
it was loud though man he was cool yeah
dude he's my faith he's the number one
guest that I ever wanted to have since
I've since damn that I used to think
about in my kitchen you may stop doing
it now I don't know man
I mean I don't know who else we get you
know Nostradamus killer might Wow
yeah killer Mike but is he run the
jewels as healing run the jewels yeah
hit the white boy no one touched the
white boy ever who run the dude yeah
jewels or somebody's run the jewels
who's run I think he's run at the big I
don't know who's what um yeah what are
we talking about we took my booty
rightful whose were we talking about
Lucy oh my god
cuz he's checking over three dead [ __ ]
out loud he goes he goes bro this [ __ ]
is crazy for white guys like you and me
good and then he called Brandon 100%
Mexican dude obviously he's been
listening to the podcast yeah he must be
right damn I didn't know he was such a
fan yeah we should mail him a shirt or
something yeah what this yeah yeah give
them something it's not Snuggie it's um
what does it call when something has
like [ __ ]
no no boxy no bras you look boxy I do
yeah you look like I could work at FedEx
man Oh put it in there you know we'll
mail it yeah Oh put it in that mean man
looks uniform like yeah there we got a
shirt right there yeah oh there's known
I've ever seen dalia for a second please
he'll make that at home most ratchets
should have two BAM
and we all got some wretched in it sure
was so ratchet hey brother there's no
one looted the [ __ ] studio they'd
leave that I think I think we hadn't
been looted here a couple times let me
show you what we had to give boo see
right there that would that needed to be
on the table man whoa the only way to
get him through the podcast
he just asked man he said hey man what
kind of refreshments do sprite like real
[ __ ] he suck I want that long sprite
[Laughter]
diet either
I want that Code Red up in my hair ways
maybe that was it man that was to Pam I
was a pound and Mick security for us to
say yeah we just send Nick Nick I mean
happy I'm George Jung and Nick got it
from where Koreatown my girl my girl
friends vegan I should I'm saying too
much knows where I got it from that's
all I had to say come on man come on
mine oh they had I think their car and a
weed bro and boozy left dude I swear to
god they empty one of them one of the
bags right into the future that yeah and
you saw the car even the tires got a
little lower brother whole car just got
high brand a little bit slower dude I
came out to your boy and Houston this
weekend hit the Browse no no wow nopal
wall you did people like it
that's a lot of white people over they
weren't into it no they were into it
yeah
Paul drywall bruh who is that is that a
rapper ahead of that oh thank God for
the one named Paul drywall or that could
be constructing that was actually
construction group over there off Holly
one night oh maybe it's Paul's drywall
yeah Paul's drywall that's a real place
Oh
oh I've seen them before Marion Texas
yeah Marion inmates it's a shutout
Paul's D walbro if you slow baby
if you tired of having in wet walls in
your house you tired of hanging up a
painting and it just slips off road cuz
the wall can handle it he looked your
boy Pauly
yeah Paul got the driest walls rise when
things dry you see a cactus karate a
wall and she wall yeah do you might have
to get up in the morning to put down
conditioned on your walls do that a
restaurant down 40 dog really oh yeah
some waitress can I start you off with
some refreshments or maybe some
appetizers just throw a Tater Tot from
the kitchen I catch a now he's so right
my [ __ ] trap right in my face over
yeah yeah deep throated them ribs just
is that a shoulder a human shoulder you
know and I want to give a [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was tasty and long that's that Viet
[Music]
damn bro run it brah I'm about to give
his lids done [ __ ] baskin-robbins
whatever your co-hosts name is that
guy's got 75 years worth of flavors
brother he's starting to look like the
drummer from that movie with
what's-his-name with teller the old
drummer with that call oh no I'm glad
you know he's starting to look like the
coach yeah yeah yeah he's also in
spider-man the old older gentleman yeah
the older gentleman that he was a coach
and uh what's that movie called great
movie would you set it whiplash whiplash
yeah oh uh JD Nelson JR Simmons Simmons
wait didn't he write Harry Potter to JK
JK Rowling
yeah violence a little bit like him but
Brian get er done
whereas get his legs done his lives what
is eyelids yeah ooh they do look similar
but Brian's here's a little more
Holly's chuck-e-cheese McWatters eyes a
problem I don't know I currently are
starting to droop he says I'm playing
you gone under the knife go and get that
nose done see thing you're two-for-one
Casteel wants in as well freaking
ratchet ratchet ratchet house do boo see
one of the best things Lucy had was uh
what was the video he talked about
[Music]
Dwyane Wade's son remember when they
wanted the son to be a woman that's 12
year old son uh-huh
and he uh he was like come on mine
Dwyane Wade man come on he's got a
Planet Fitness bra and he's like [ __ ]
bra platf is eight dollars a month bro
here at a planet yeah I don't know if
they'll do video on there is that come
on man
they don't even know where it's weird
they don't even know they don't even
know what they mix me Ogilvie they don't
we don't have figured out [ __ ] he might
meet a woman anything at sixteen in a
fall in love with yeah but it's gonna be
gone idle like brothers you going to
follow and that's wax man it was trying
to tax but I don't think they were even
talking about cut his dick off what did
wait but man would they not though
potentially there well yeah but some
people will they will think okay let's
they're in the Hollywood circle let's do
it you know there was what's a penis
amongst a family you know what's a penis
looks you know what I'm saying now he'd
be nice one less dick around here I'm
just saying man people start to you know
I just
it's [ __ ] I hit is 12 years old you
don't know if he's man come on man oh my
oh my twelve thousand even transformers
like me ask my dad to [ __ ] put robot
arms on me and him doing it then when
I'm 21 I'm like you asked for it yeah
look I'm 12 doing I was 12 I just
watched a weird move yeah the [ __ ]
bumblebee yeah come on come on you don't
even know where the next meal coming
from on swing way my dad drunk when he's
doing it bro oh yeah I dunno like that
whatever man you don't know [ __ ] like
weekend at Bernie's talk you don't know
[ __ ] bro if I was [ __ ] bro if I was [ __ ]
you wouldn't even know me dog come on my
each whale years old mine he can't
complain way you can't be cutting his
dick all mine that was a hot second ago
right when we came out and said that and
then we didn't talk about it on the pod
baby there's the one in the red bowtie
trying to cut him I'm mistaken for
Dwayne Wade right now man I have to be
around that dude sometimes be cool yeah
being around to Wayne bringing about to
be around meanwhile you reached out to
MC Hammer and [ __ ] Bootsy fella right
we get him ro kill you brother Fred
Durst on here don't kill me man all
we're saying is he's 12 years old man
yeah
lines but I don't think someone come to
tick off though well I think boots eater
get another level yeah boots you might
have took it another level
yeah they said that the Sun though they
named the gender don't even know God
don't make mistakes
Hitler says hold my beer I guess there
they are but anyway look that's a touchy
subject yeah it's a touchy subject but
it but that was booties reaction but
anyway yeah it was awesome having a man
are y'all from the same area I thought
no he's from Baton Rouge I'm from
Covington so about an hour but my
brother lives kind of where he grew up
but now he lives in Atlanta is New
Orleans still lockdown hmm I mean dude
houston they were roasting people who
had masks on really oh I was wearing my
through the airport people point really
well what about like the rest of the
city so you found a barbecue joint but
that doesn't mean the whole place is a
hold of it I went to bars what about I'm
always open rollerskating or anything
like that
all the mall was packed everywhere the
mauled the the the comedy place was you
know 75% full people eating drinking how
was the vibe there dope was it yeah
they're so appreciative that someone
came out there you couldn't do
meet-and-greets huh I was down to do it
the club for insurance purposes I wanted
to do it yeah but we would go out the
back of me people yeah that's what we're
about Brian the meze older you know oh
yeah I know it gets late to that second
show Brian yeah I see what you're
talking about
oh I'll give them a quarter-inch of nut
skin to patch some of them bastards oh
because that's what they do you know it
really they take part of your scrotum or
scrotum or whatever and put it on yeah
yeah I'll give you half a best I mean
less I need less
Maka's a miser thin man look at mine
when I smile about what my people use my
like Chin's yeah
nice mild stuff to see we all got kind
of you ever probably around the size in
yours cat cat actually I feel like
you're the most open eyes like I feel
like G and C huh all Chappell Oh
big worm big worm yeah oh yeah my money
I'm killing you and your friends you
know and he passed away didn't he did
not he did not okay right he choked out
a valley a valley person did he know who
I saw driving here was deal hugely I see
him probably right there big on my homey
does bootleg made this [ __ ] Australia
does bootleg he makes a lot of love from
German its German no Oh y'all talking
about these old-ass movies what movie
y'all gonna talk about next honest old
Land Before Time or Triceratops
little foot with y'all gonna break up
next man huh
grease Brooke you know barbershop one
what else y'all gonna bring a barbershop
we there yet
i watch Robocop the other night really
into Robocop really brilliant a Robocop
cuz I'm Mortal Kombat can download
Robocop now I forgot the new Mortal
Kombat huh yeah doc download the bonus
characters the Joker Robocop Wow
we're all coming over I'm telling you
come over then I don't always say that
is it oh [ __ ] maybe Taco Tuesday night
okay alright
it's cuz of curfew so I mean I might
hang [ __ ] right I'll tell y'all I'll
tell you this right now you bout to get
shot with a rubber bullet coming around
West Hollywood you're a freshly come at
me dude I got the new kill try to hit a
rut
turn around other people that should
yeah higher son break a chair though no
you got
never put your chair together for youto
logic cuts around here let shooters came
here with no there's only piss on the
walls it just on the walls man they
already got this place I like that show
on the walls man we all got some ratchet
in us man what else is going on dude
what's up with you chin our Chin's been
looting really nah man but in my area is
super crazy downtown Wow like really
really crazy and what do you like what's
the vibe and like what have you did you
go out have you met anybody out are you
doing
no man when I see them walking so
there's huge crowds in the streets so I
feel like if I walk down there
something's gonna happen and then
there's just tons and tons of cops are
on Mike I posted a video it's like what
30 cops in a row constantly when we're
on just driving around dude I feel like
I'm walking out there they're gonna
arrest me that's I feel Wow what cuz why
because your ethnicity or because just
the rest just cuz I'm outside just cuz
I'm outside dude out when we're out dude
in Houston man I saw the Wrights going
I'm a Annapolis stuff like that and I
didn't know homeboy who was murdered was
from Houston oh when they started protec
because we're staying downtown and I was
outside we're getting ready to go the
the club to do the shows and I see like
probably 20 cop cars come flying by him
like dance with me rob a bank my dumb
ass and then I see a military like
Hummer come by like oh [ __ ] and I walk
down I see a copy of what's going on use
I'll get out of here fire you the
protest about to start man he's like
we're gonna shut this area down you
won't be able to get in or out for a few
hours and you're like well they have
funnel cake corn up there he's like get
the [ __ ] didn't you have the wake up
Brian from his nap yeah bro let me taste
some man it's scared to go out your
house right now
yeah scary out there man who's not
scared yeah post mates post Malone
postmates start oh really yeah it's like
an assistant at your beacon called
Wow man I want that beacon call man I
want that beacon cheeseburger you feel
me go do it
they will yeah whatever you want you
want a slice of pie for your fat mouth
yeah Doug oh dude I want that teriyaki
hitter Oh bro I want them to tie a damn
pork chop to a baseball bat and just
beat me right in the damn throat with
that sucker but they will drop it off
post mates picks it up whatever you want
you order your takeout from your local
favorite restaurants you guys need to be
supporting your neighborhood spots right
now more than ever wipe me down baby
just download the post mates app on iOS
or Android find your favorites and get
anything you want delivered within the
hour
dang bro post mates has given you guys
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app use the code
Kay 80s 2020 yeah that's code Kay 80s to
zero to zero for $100 of free delivery
credit man for your first seven days
when you download the post mates app
anything you need anytime you need it
post bateson I'll tell you this man yeah
Paul while they're having a walk for
George Floyd today at 3:00 p.m. I saw
Paul wall posted in Houston yeah there
they damn they did it early this morning
in Venice I mean yeah Brian sent maybe
across the street 30 cops out front of a
bikini at all cost what's a bikini how
dare you this is Street Street in their
most expensive street in California is
it really no it's dope no it's dope they
have everything
it's a white money I got expensive
street money come on now yeah we can
have everything down there done my boy
the an Adidas store you got Jelena take
away they got uh II just thought we're
advance that's a lot of Jews a lot of
whites it's a lot of whites and a lot of
white fence and whites I'm not gonna
give where Brian lives but if you turn
that camera
[Laughter]
but yeah they're having a big walk Paul
walls did they having a big walk today
oh yeah he posted it he follows me he
does yeah the people's challenge hear me
spit that verse and then he now I need a
grill let me see yeah I need a grill I
want one with a gap - no I can't have
that's what that's what I was saying
yeah I can't exactly I mean the gap
because the gap is like my thing you
like Michael Strahan of comedy what did
you call me Strahan Strahan bro his game
way bigger than mine ya think
look at that [ __ ] bring up my this gap
is bigger yeah brah I don't know if I
have any pictures of me smiling but it's
called the occipital we get a that was
called occipital I think yours is the
same as strands let me see yours yeah
you got that view years a little slimmer
yeah children's gap you have to slim
Jean caps don't notice if you have one
day Strahan got that 710 split
no you need an extra frame to pick that
thing up man he got that hippo - he
messed up for that dude he got that cab
catch a break that big Whistler we got
that Tommy said almost a billion views
son oh yeah yeah really
oh [ __ ] damn you men they went out of
business man the only thing on that
thing is still in businesses you oh well
brah dude I was fatter there look at me
now I've been jump roping yeah but you
also you wore that that shirts got you
you were a really cagey shirt you gonna
match the back blue on blue hey didn't
tell me and that's the only rule brutal
man otherwise it can't you know it's
tough but I literally saw the stage when
they said you're up next
no way really yes they did show me a pre
and there's like are you up and then I
walk out to like 800 people I was like
what the [ __ ] is up with y'all and
you're like you know they start
listening [ __ ]
it was cool shouts out all those people
for like my where was that at Chappelle
that was in San Fran at the Comedy
Central
what the what the hell is that first
cluster fest that Coach Festa the cops
or no they do know it's if they do it at
the Bill Graham our auditorium is in the
side room right yeah yeah I remember I
did a set in there oh yeah you was there
too
Sanka when the pilot say because
surpasses every year and then yeah that
was that was 2019 those when does 2019
oh yeah I said let's face my teeth man
is facing teeth they say what what is it
what is the yeah but turn four
yeah what do they say about it chin I
really I think sorry history of it yeah
I think it's just called [ __ ] up teeth
Oh Dan y'all ice cold my mom and dad got
girls they did yeah
praise God brother my mom never smaller
the pictures really yeah I think I think
they're cool I think yeah it's cool I
want to get it fixed
dude would you rather have a gap or
[ __ ] have to swear stuff from the gap
oh I'd rather have a gap let's just pop
in those gaps hot right now no it ain't
wrong hot low right there look at this
hold I had asked you feel yeah what live
with him wet ass lips - boy I was all
alone about nine or eleven that was my
nickname run 911 now that haircut [ __ ]
that's classy bro yeah it looks like a
looter right
I was looting shampoo but look at all
that beautiful hair dude people mistake
me for a horse sometime people just come
and get on my back from nobody
let me let me see your cab now oh yeah
oh yeah oh you got money veneers ha ha
I got Q veneers here two-face nice to
know you get the wise - yeah that's
pills teeth pretty white let me see your
teeth absolutely they're pretty white
though she looks like barbecue corn nuts
it's called I asked him up by the way
diastema I just like that yeah mr.
Callum row though dog that's the real
hitter yeah I got that big as I seen me
right you can barely get to my bottom
row man
I was gonna lay back oh I'll put a dip
of toothpaste in my mouth and it's leave
it in there but because it's hard to get
all of these I didn't know for the first
couple years of my life you even had
teeth at the bottom I thought it was
tops only man and one day my brother
took that toothbrush and put it right
here and pulled my lip name he said look
here you idiot I got a lot of rot and I
got a lot of I don't know man let me see
that enamel boy mask we got rid of the
gap huh man man man and that yeah you
shouldn't prove that [ __ ] Chappelle you
got rid of it I know I'm out doughnuts
Oh - hello Birds its but I saved my
trays but he got jumped he did yeah was
something he got jumped or something
they had to get his teeth fixed
he still could have got them fixed the
old way of gap - said Nick a little bit
yeah bro I've had I've had a lot of
ladies trauma one time I was dunking off
a skateboard ramp onto like a 9-foot
hoop jumping off yeah yeah we were
running and dunking off onto like a
9-foot hoop and it ripped my entire
tooth out like the whole route and
everything would you catch it in the net
or something yeah
skateboard ramp there's but either way I
needed the boost and it was only nine
feet still but did it hurt honestly it
didn't it was like shock and then I'm
like I'm like our almighty sillier
almighty still there and they're like no
and but then I was at a I was at a
months ago was in seventh grade my
friend I was actually at a friend's
house whose mom was a dentist and he was
like mom put it in milk I read it in
your waiting room because it keeps it
alive the calcium in the milk and then
they they actually put it back in I had
it for years
type-moon yeah yeah I put it in milk he
didn't she didn't know and he did
shoutout time durant you still talked
that kid
my roommate right now yeah my god this
is like a damn 34:30 yeah you ride or
die take your tooth now I just came
along yeah he moved out here like a
couple years before me and I've been
living in the same like budget-ass
apartment for the whole time he'll pay
the man more no I'm just stacking it
they're actually trying to knock it down
but they can't cause a culvert right now
but like six months I'm gonna have to
move but I'm ready you live with your
girl - uh basically I'm at her place way
more than I am my place do they have to
pay you to move out of your place - if
they try and take it over
ah cuz you don't own it yeah the
landlord is gonna get compensated
somehow and they're like they can do
where they weren't gonna please yeah
yeah but I think at the land
I feel like soon as the lease is up
thinking do what the [ __ ] that was I had
friends that lived at places and they
were gonna somebody was taking over the
building and they were gonna remodel or
they were selling and they had to give
them a payment to move out yeah I just
know the renter laws in California like
protect the renter like I don't know I
feel like I could squat there for years
and I stay broke I'm ready to move on
cute do you realize are all 35 roommates
and no one's that shows full of [ __ ] you
know expensive that place would be in
Manhattan New York
I don't bake those [ __ ] apartments
worth I never saw one episode of friends
neither seen a few but right away I
smelled [ __ ] really yeah them always
making fun of Phoebe and Joey know damn
well they had CT yeah well don't call
him out dude you're supposed to be
secretive about this [ __ ] CT recognizes
but nobody believed that believes that
somebody with CT he's gonna recognize
somebody else's CT
oh you'd be surprised man smelled a mile
away brother that's coming off your own
dome I thank my dog you got that heavy
dense brush melt every time I go in here
brother the Lord doubled if you
like a Dairy Queen Co you got that
double dip right no uh-uh
Dairy Dairy Queen fans I used to like
their cones I like what they do
sometimes with some of their had a
blizzard I like cold on man I like
[ __ ] blizzard sir kevro you said
blizzard three times that's delicious
man I don't like how you haven't had one
I've had one man you don't even letting
me talk I said I'll I don't like a lot
of their entrees but I like some of the
yeah some of the sweets they have some
of the desserts you don't like that you
don't go there for a chili dog
no but no one eats lunch at Dairy Queen
you [ __ ] doing its Dairy Queen sorry
Taco Tuesday guy guy who has different
types of food at his house bro you rich
[ __ ] no I'm sorry
you for my bad dog and we invite you all
the [ __ ] time forgetting about us
regular ass people down here you know I
put some [ __ ] salt on this shirt and
eat this [ __ ] dog I'll grill up a
[ __ ] tank top [ __ ] hot eats cool
treats trying to push that [ __ ] on
everybody no eating chili dogs and their
wrinkly ass fries dude I'll put some IO
Leon a [ __ ] brassiere and grill that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah oh wow blizzard all
day file I mean I do like I never get a
banana split I always get the blizzard I
don't think I've ever seen anybody order
a banana split under the age of 50 that
is an adult tree oh yeah could people
like to reminisce about their child and
once they get over 50 they'd like to
have reminiscent treats bruh
you like to have something to remind you
of back in the day good yeah I'll get me
a sugar scoop or I'll get me a banana
split so y'all know [ __ ] that shit's
magical you go there's your banana split
right there Randy that's a different
kind of banana split bro
oh yeah not another team move not
another team I know I have no idea Chris
Evans is this Chris Evans dude is also a
stripper I think we look up Chris Evans
stripper you don't have to do it the
porn blockers on my computer Chris Evans
stripper New Orleans Oh Downton to
bottom right that looks more of a
thunder down under' dude no that's that
[ __ ] Joey Joey yeah from blossom yeah
yeah he danced for a while what about
Chris Evans New Orleans what did you
look up Chris Evans New Orleans do when
times get tough and you got a body on
it's good way to make money though huh
uh yeah but the problem is that really
if you don't have a body on you didn't
really you're not welcome in there yeah
well that makes sense huh oh boy uh the
dude from French Quarter stripper
where's that gonna go down under the
crib French Quarter stripper right there
they say most strippers your boy who you
like that
the dude from 21 Jump Street yeah I
might have the rope-a-dope champagne was
like a jet stripper was he yeah you know
what Adam Hunter was a stripper comedian
he's a stripper
I wanted to do it he started wrestling
with people I think I was gay yeah
there's the stripper that starts fresh
money
he's like he put you in a [ __ ] dude
wasn't the worst stripper of all time
Brad it was good brah he's exotic man
he's funny guy man he are and he also
he'll put you in that rear naked choke
heavy on the naked he all stripper row
he doesn't dance no he danced years ago
yeah years ago yeah let's start this
shout out at a minor man yeah let's get
into this [ __ ] show dogus piece of
[ __ ] so off the heels of the success of
our new segment last week cats DMS we
want to do it again but I just assumed
it'd be all guys just trying to get on
the show diem and cat I'm sure you got
some weird ones this week dude yeah I
want that Bernardo
yeah people say yeah I want to train
that dark doll dude I got people come on
the streets I'm gonna let me slip your
ass then laughing like disgusting man
you guys are disgusting so we brought in
a special guest to do it good afternoon
young lady and can you turn the camera
again yeah what's going on Anna actually
been fixing my grandparents roof today
oh sweet of you leaking I mean I don't
know anything about that stuff but my
dad oh nice
we are just still sitting here in the
same place you left us in we're good to
see we're happy we're good to see you
today is it crazy where you're at or the
protests and stuff for now it's not too
crazy here but I live in the middle of
nowhere
yeah do you we went to the beach this
past weekend and they wouldn't let us in
some places because they were worried
that protestors were about to be there
what beach did y'all go to Panama state
oh yeah
yet aha spring right down there we
buried a friend of mine down there and I
swear to God I don't know if we ever dug
it so fine post did you go to spring
break there ever I did we only a few
hours yeah yeah I like the beach so I
like going to Destin - Destin is
beautiful oh yeah we both fish down
there oh yeah well we're gonna read some
of her dm's because she's on her phone
cats gonna read it for oh yes not just
from catfish you feel me
did you hear from any people that watch
this show or no I did where they decent
people went to school with and knew
personally listened to y'all's podcast I
love it Oh little rural Alabama yeah my
well we had a lot of people asking us
about you - I think everybody I ran into
was curious about the fishing curious
about that fish and girl you know just
wanted to really your your big fan they
loved you yes ma'am all right well
speaking of noodling let's hear this
some of the messages that came and Kat
has them right here so this one says how
much do I have to pay for news because I
will literally send any amount Wow hmm I
bet and have you ever considered on and
I mean you know I'm not I'm not judging
you really wanted really big male
friends when I'm has mullet
yeah I'm really considered like sending
them pictures of him hilarious make sure
you get the money first though you know
upfront money upfront matures cash you
have money up front and penis up front
if you send a nude apparently dude said
he will literally send any amount of
money though so pick a number yeah would
you ever consider that on any level I
mean I think everybody you know even if
you made it look like art or something
like it here I know what I'm talking
about how to get a tan maybe they're
just like you know Sonia Singh and hold
the fish up the block muster the parts
yeah what if you held a fish that
blocked like all the other like you'd be
surprised
check that out
let's hear a couple more that came in so
this one starts off saying nice belly
are you that strong smiling emoji hey
want to have sex whoa okay you know he's
direct though yep and have you ever met
a man through your DMS on IG that you
went on a date with or anything not
since before anybody knew who I was and
I just had like a thousand followers
yeah yeah smart
yeah that's pretty normal yeah because
now it can be a lot of it can be a lot
of transients really passing through
there a lot of catfish no pun intended
yeah yeah a lot of real bull heads if
you know what I'm saying let's read
another one of these that came in hey
when you coming when you coming fishing
in the UK we have some good Pike and
tout I think he means trout we'd love to
show you around I want to settle on your
fishy bits whoa chuckle clean it up
John away Jay now did you suckle are you
more
it's at least nice that it came from
abroad though it said yes nice you know
what I'm saying there is your worldwide
Hanna's worldwide and have you ever
considered have you ever thought of
doing like a noodling Expo you know
traveling and doing that in some sort of
way or know so many different states
it's hard because catfishing is just
like any other thing you don't ever know
how good it's gonna go or how bad we had
a Canadian oh yeah what do you think
about it what do you think about really
him and and how do they how do you set
this up with him obviously not to dm's
I'm sure you have a legit site cuz you
can't just be DM and these dudes but
yeah come on down and give an address
and how much do you tip like how much is
it to go on a tour cuz I feel like you
could probably charge with more of an
exclusive rate you know then somebody
like one of us yeah
or that shirtless guy we saw a couple of
here that shirtless guy that older man
no maybe it was it could have been is
your dad out of shape no dad could
probably charge a lot more money though
yeah this dude was fully together not
ripped at all
how much do you - how much is a noodling
experience how much is that experience -
I feel like you could charge a premium
charger license both yeah well I bet
people would pay a pretty penny for that
experience especially some of these guys
because this next text right here said
what did it say
I'll pay you $40 for a pic of your poop
oh my god no and that's bait in some
countries that's why fielding catch any
fish Oh tell her how you didn't catch
any fish oh yeah we feel should you some
tips he went he went fishing he got
nothing
I didn't even get a dang bite I mean
heck I didn't even I used cat food for a
little while and we used worms and cat
food
seafood see and what are you had a
little bait in your arm or something you
put a little oh no you just stick your
hand in the hole that's like that's like
but it's believing in the Lord you just
got to go in there and free let's read
this next one this one says I see you're
pretty good at hint I see you're pretty
good at noodling but can you handle a
noodle would you question how many do
you get that use noodle in that respect
it's like an easy leap I feel like a lot
of its hat and do you open all of these
do you open them all up these days do
you respond to them or everyone you
respond to some every once in a while I
respond any of them like this I just
screenshot yeah noodling through these
perverts I bet it is let's hear let's
hear another one this next one ain't
entertaining
this one says putting your hands on
those fish you'll like putting them on
something else smirky emoji just kidding
I was talking about fishing the whole
time please don't block me I jerk off to
you with my two inch collar that if you
want could be inside of you
sorry it was my friend that wasn't your
friend this is sad I'm sorry this
happened to you oh my god this is kind
of vulgar to know when that one was a
little I just like this REO is my friend
but yeah I didn't
well yeah I'm sorry yeah they got I'm
sorry this is happening to you and I'm
sorry most I think most attractive girls
deal with this though yeah yeah it's
probably it's good to bring awareness to
it it's probably there in the Lord's
work really what's that Hannah know if
it ever works yeah yeah they're shooting
their shot to putting their hands in the
dark murky waters helping you bite yeah
and here's one more this one's kind of
cute actually if your standards are as
low as your squats that one's fun pretty
cute
you know Amy Schumer odd she met not her
husband but the guy she dated for years
she met him on our Instagram on DMS he's
a chef right and this is before that guy
this guy this man made tables table man
beautiful man - I met him I think his
name was Chris now that that's her
current husband but anyway but yeah
people meet people you know well I think
that's like 80% of people meet online
with its DMS or a dating app is there a
phishing dating app like groupers R Us
or something yeah we could say if you're
looking for business ideas that's do you
could if you want yeah if you wanted to
start a fishing dating app I think that
would be a go fish yeah that'd be a kid
yeah Brendan they already have a fishing
date again what do you is there product
or something you do sell is there
something that you sell so is there some
Hannah Mertz that we could get I'm
actually working on oh yeah we talked
about that you come up to designs for us
to put on some shirts well we will rock
it here yeah if you send us some we'll
rock them whenever you get them we need
to l and a double XL bouncing but you
can outlet rock
come catfish oh no we're down oh yeah I
think I think kovetz over yeah kovetz
over see as long as he goes first I'll
stand behind Brennan and hold on to his
back I promise I'm down to do it yeah if
you don't mind up two men and one riding
piggyback with the fish I don't that
scares the fish away but we'll try it
I'll be the net I'll be the guy with
that net boy okay Brendan faints - I'll
go in there you know I'm that backup
yeah well yeah Hannah you gotta let us
know when you got some merch we'd love
to sport it and we're sorry that we're
sending a lot of these perverts your way
I think the creeps are there before
though just seeing a little worse yeah
do you ever get me haters who would hate
on you do you ever get really oh yeah
really and they're like god the only
reason the owners you catch those fish
is because you got a nice body
you know the excuses that's the one I
want to see them the hate is real Oh
[ __ ] you're gonna kill these fish we
don't kill you alright put my hand down
your throat is it women or men Wow
I know I know how these Asian women or
men that send you the death threats
usually that other that don't have the
angry stuff though damn do you get the
only reason you're catching these fish
because you're pretty the suck at fish
is called Tara Hannah
I'd like look if you reached into my
whole lot bite I tell you Oh
yeah by twice but that's cuz he bite
twice kid he eats a lot that's yeah I go
for seconds well hanaway yeah obviously
we're turning into some of those
partners so we're gonna set a few of
those so right we're gonna shut it down
now
but let us know when you get those
shirts we want to wear some of them I'm
sure well I do appreciate it yeah thank
you so much for brightening up our day
yeah you're the best good luck with the
fish thank you well we're down we gotta
get out under the table laughter I'll
get that [ __ ] eye so it's a bad trait
when I get turned on one eye it's a
little lazy we got Tom Segura some
different can say yeah this Walmart body
cook right here
not this guy I don't talk about Thomas a
girl hey Theo hey Brennan I got a debate
club for you
my girlfriend is a liberal and I am a
conservative do you think it will work
or do you think we should just give up
we're getting arguments all the time
over politics and I love her and we get
along great most of the time but I don't
know I'm just wondering your thoughts on
it yeah so let's say fire Nick at the
end
did they got monster energy I don't
think the [ __ ] you bro he's had to
listen to a liberal for years he said
there's Tory burnt some let's forget I
did that no it's okay it's a good
question what is joking man that'd be
tough man like my dad so scared this
COBIT stuff for this Trump stuff I mean
him I mean we can't you we can't even
talk politics Iturbi but I try to just
stay away from it I can't mention it him
go rap war man he kicks your ass well I
just keep sending fat I just keep
dropping fats on his ass yeah I think
it's hard to deal what's hard to deal
with anybody that's extreme I find it's
hard to deal with anybody that's extreme
one way or the other from me sir I find
it hard to do it like I prom my prom
it's not my problem like let's say feel
was super whatever against some I
believe that you don't have to not like
the person who gives a [ __ ] yeah so it's
Theo you know I don't care what he
believes in politics that's fine you
have to hate so much of their political
views yes some people won't like
somebody because of their political
views like I don't get that part like up
here yeah I have bigger I just have you
know bigger fish turf I just have more
things that are more important but
politics have always been a one of those
things they say you don't talk about it
you know you don't weird to me because
it's like you're if you do if you vote
fit like ask my dad when Hillary and
Trump were vote I want who'd you vote
for us come on that's personally okay
but is it so personal tell me you voted
for and why well now you're starting
like conversations with you start in the
argument we're on board we're on board
we're on the same page until all that
stuff happened you start in the [ __ ] but
see how fired up people get yeah when
you're their own son and you try to ruin
their lives by continually start you
know but if that's if you should if
you're super strong minded in politics
your thing and your girls against it
ain't gonna work
that's tidy I think it can be tough
wouldn't a girl fight over flamin hot
cheetos little own politics you know me
if politics your thing it's not gonna
work man Brenda you always fighting over
food yeah you are yeah very true dude
you're instigating
come on over dog your I went to my
barber that Goldilocks you up yeah wit
I told hit up my barber it's like a
speakeasy yeah coming you back like that
green wall yeah I told you the English
yeah very little you Scott you get a
dangle bueno bueno there's your pictures
hair vatos baby showing off pictures
yeah a lot of tried to scroll here they
[ __ ] your [ __ ] up yet every Walia that
exist and I saw that that's not a green
wall what'd the guy look like that did
your hair short little Mexican dude word
who's a G was he yeah and not what age
group was he and you think it's tough to
tell it's tough to tell they all look
very similar
yeah it's tough did he take a long
thought was it my guy it was he he goes
brunt Brendan sent you to bully listen
to your [ __ ] we don't talk yeah
what do you guys think about this what
do you eat think cuz it is interesting
man if you're if you're and God bless
this fella that sent this and he's
obviously hiding in the garage from his
spouse at the moment or she locked him
in the garage you could tell you know
there's only that one window in there
with them he had to be quiet
yeah very quiet so it looks like he's
not even allowed to do that much what do
you what do you think my dad my dad
loves trot my mom hates Trump but
they're both Republican I mean I never
really had an issue with it cuz politics
don't really run our lives like that
yeah yeah same yeah whatever yeah yeah
does the great Brian count said get
involved politics otherwise can get
involved with you what yeah you better
learn that [ __ ] they start taking on
your rights and she can start getting
involved and know who to vote for in
[ __ ] some of this stuff I sit back and
then they control your control you know
I get I didn't understand your dude that
came in hot
got it I understand it was just lost
well some of the centrist ships since
her censorship stuff does get real scary
oh you Tom taking us out out of the
algorithm because you know my talk you
know Hannah's fine ass there you know
profanity yeah
profanity she can't cuss in the first
five minutes and good can't stamp other
people's music a pair well yeah but
waiter you have to be liberally used
taught me Twitter's only it's really you
know it really channels more a lot more
I don't even know if liberally used to
when I was young it was just like
Republican and Democrat but now
everything's so much more people have so
many more diverse thoughts though to
sharing thoughts to their way or the
highway yeah scary yeah that is scary
man it's like comment be [ __ ] down
because people have to live together
that's the thing about the country
everybody you know we do all have to
live here so it's like and everybody has
the right to so it's it's a real traffic
jam bro I love you all man and media
covers it like team sports like it's red
vs. blue my team for you your team like
CNN and and ESPN they look exactly the
same they're the same show and it's like
it shouldn't be that should be issues
like yeah well CNN and Fox you watch Fox
News is like two one will paint one
patient one plate the other and they're
both extreme there's no middle yeah so
you can find your confirmation whatever
you're looking for yeah that's the thing
too now you can get exactly what you
want so there's really fortifies how you
feel I'm this guy but I think mainstream
media is the enemy of the state
yeah I agree that's a great movie by the
way
well that when especially when the news
if you listen because the news can
really start to form how you how you
think to but remember the news I'm gonna
fall any Bravo Sam Tripoli but remember
the news all they give a flying [ __ ]
about is rate oh yeah they make no sense
so since this whole death of that that
poor dude in Minneapolis have you heard
anything about koban your him time I
think about kovin have you heard one
thing about kovin where's where's the
big grandpa what's this ramped up their
time out don't not be a Breitbart
another protest whispers where's the
breakouts where's the Republican state
that opened up like Georgia and Florida
all these states open where's where's
the second coming where's the heat wave
where we talking about we are that I
know that's crazy
it did what say your [ __ ] it's crazy to
think how many places are making money
off of the riots and stuff making money
off of the part you know like there's
people like people are making money off
of George Floyd's death you know what
I'm saying like they're making money off
of it it's crazy to think that the news
gets to make money off of that what else
you got yeah sorry
give me yeah it's interesting though
that when people starts talking about
this kind of [ __ ] this the kind of [ __ ]
this do probably the deals of every day
it is dinner imagine trying to do you
know finish off polish off a churro or
something with somebody you're getting
yourself a bowl of something you know a
ham soup or something you seem like you
kind of got it was slipper cut a ham
into a bank in a dam so a real shoot
like you'd be angry pork chop my soup
I'm gonna turn it down I gonna push it
away the guy who had half of a frickin
farm on his plate at the beginning of
this thing for the table and then we
washed it down with a doughnut from
voodoo doughnuts good oh the best sub s
and what is it real they don't have it
is there's a thick shot like I like a
thick chocolate glazed dog it's like
right it's perfect it's perfect right
yeah oh yeah Portland that's where they
started yeah Ray's God bro we all got
some ratchet in his mind so what do we
tell the guy King it I don't even should
he call it quits or give it a shot it's
gonna be a long road brother it's be a
long road yeah you can't I think you
can't control sometimes who you love man
I think sometimes like there will be
people and even though they have a ton
of things that bug you and stuff you
still love them I think sometimes you
can't control that kind of I'll be
open-minded
man what'd he say he is a conservative
yeah maybe a little open-minded to the
side she's coming from yeah they're
gonna try to get us for a hate crime bro
just ain't the time to be doing that
kind of [ __ ] to tell ya hands up
waterboarded yourself yeah I do
hands up don't sit brah you got a chill
what else you got Nick he's a beautiful
family right here and it knows real
children they are and this is a debate
club more wholesome do Vaughn Brendan
Schaub hey we're just sitting here in
quarantine a Pheo
me and my wife wouldn't want to walk
down the out of that Bishop gun hitter
yeah play my call on this past weekend
but we're just here with my new toy my
new baby boy we were having a debate so
we wanted to be with you
the new or the old lion king Oh bro you
tell us they probably watch it 17 times
like me and Baz buzz poopy diapers PD
dog dang bro congratulations on the nuts
on that beautiful cup right there
this is Mark
[Music]
that's so cool man love this dope tight
that's a great thanks man yeah that's
awesome man and the rest of you won't
feel liking the newer the old dude the
new is some [ __ ] listen if I want it
real that National Geographic I want I
want my Disney [ __ ] man you know I'm
saying also Beyonce [ __ ] it up [ __ ] it
up dude yeah have you seen it a new
thing
yeah it's weak you have to go on these
riffs and [ __ ] is weak man was it the
old ones way better Elton John singing
that [ __ ] like my own it sounds like
Kermit the Frog hold on is this you
don't know [ __ ] man remember I told you
that earlier you forgot I remember come
on man you forgot
definitely definitely an old Lion King
though that cartoons look I think it's
hard to replace things for people man if
it's younger people they watch the old
when it looks old to them so they only
know that it's it's funner you know I'm
saying like this New Age ship that we're
doing like Batman I don't need the real
story of Batman I don't need my Bruce
Wayne being in the real world I like
that old [ __ ] Batman Returns mr. freeze
yeah everybody come on do it come on
kill me do it
it's not like an Irish dude hold our act
in a bag come on do it to my TV come on
do it now kill me that's pretty good I'm
good right you full of [ __ ]
you probably starving bro you like spelt
lightheaded Grossman give me yeah you
got water in your lungs you out of your
damn mind right now man your little out
of you got waterboarded what abort
yourself bro yeah I don't like the
new-age [ __ ] the Batman's the
superheroes I don't like that [ __ ] you
have a look I struggle with a lot of the
remakes stuff man you know I like a lot
of the originals but I haven't seen the
new king the the new lion Kings yeah
don't waste your time you my son halfway
through what Papa I'm bored really yeah
cuz - it's too real yeah the play I saw
was good I went did go and see the play
I would that's like on my bucket list it
looks incredible the Disney play it
ruined Broadway but because now it's all
just Disney and they sell merch through
oh really Broadway yeah like it Broadway
is now like movies it's only big
blockbusters like by Disney like wicked
oh yeah I mean that's like that's one
that's kind of stood the test of time
but it's like they just keep popping out
these Disney once and it'll juice now
are they that sounds interesting but yes
so big-budget spider-man they did Logan
they all go to Broadway now wow they
found that other outlet mm-hmm yeah my
friend Dodd Loomis used to run uh
do all the he was a director or
something I think of all the yeah
and so I'm we done and watched him
sometime and it's seeing the costumes
and everything that was amazing
yeah is how talented there and then we
get paid yeah that's for the love of the
gangs or worse they paid worse than UFC
fighters yeah they're working their ass
off eight shows a week that's for the
love [ __ ] uh game right there that's the
play yeah [ __ ] looks ridiculous and all
the pieces of the costume and how they
put them all together and they move at
all it's pretty magnificent art too so
I'm gonna go with that outside issue
brother play I was hoping someone would
say that Thank You verified you knew
that information man you have
information that you know
[Laughter]
where's your wife won't you get your
wife to chime in she send a video do you
know what we believe in it gin yeah
chant however said something man hi my
wife watch us thinking you're full of
[ __ ] yeah we got four videos from your
side piece and nothing from your later
step up we were wrong dog I saw him
hanging out with her and her nieces Oh
putting wigs on him and stuff that was
pretty [ __ ] dorable yeah where did you
post that at stories waking up these
children brah beautiful dog that's
beautiful [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody in here
should say there's save their stories
and send them to me before the show so
we can look at that stuff up production
you know nothing it's a trigger for an
appeal I'm just gonna curl up and read a
good book she seems like the type that
says that you know I'm just gonna curl
up dude I bet she curls up read the book
and bakes that apple pie dog that might
be wifey for you Theo
she has a well-read little [ __ ] bro
well now you called her a [ __ ] we just
met her she looks like that little word
okay she looks like that little worm
that comes out the Apple you know I'm
saying with the class we got [ __ ] up Amy
don't eat me
yeah oh I don't know I don't know why
that apple rolling you're raising the
rent she beautiful man yes probably hurt
and when you see when you see a pie you
forget how good it is yeah you forget
how good a pie is until you see a
picture of a pie bring up a picture of a
pioneer yeah Marie Marie Callender's
when I don't yeah because they fake
breasts cuz i well know all they sold
was pie it's 2020 brazil and sugar
shapes but i didn't even sell real last
pot show me some real pie bro that's
that sugar disc there I'll tell you
right now I like a nice pecan pie myself
do you owe
a coffee or pecan nothing more unhealthy
in the pecan pie though oh yeah the
sugar you put in when you're making a
pecan pie man it's bags of sugar you
need seven eight bags bro you like
cherry pie huh you like a cherry
I don't mind it bright if it has real
cherries in it I don't like them
fake-ass cherries yeah sometime they'll
get pieces uh something else over cherry
flavor on it that should as fantastic
little have pie enough man do you
probably had a lot about pie growing up
in the Midwest on Nick I bet I was never
a big sweet guy that's right yeah I got
a lot of [ __ ] for that but yeah I feel a
mom I like meat and potatoes most people
like losing their teeth over sweets bro
Nick's like I'm taking my freaking
basketball man I'm trying to lose my
teeth off ridiculous yeah Rob Dyrdek's
my dentist
yeah I'm pissed people didn't film
everything back then I would love down
Rob Dyrdek's my sweet tooth I'll tell
you right now man I love [ __ ] pie
though homemade pie old days that was
asking homemade or store-bought treats
snow about some [ __ ] Little Debbie
can suck it oh she makes a nice dope me
up I'll give her that
no yeah we'll say I never put enough
icing you know yeah they do
[Music]
hey not for me dude huh not for me bro
well [ __ ] filled to the brim with icing
it is filled to the brim bro no you can
get bigger ones now you get the giant
patties which it's a step in the right
direction first of all we've never
called anything from Little Debbie a
patty okay cause a patty Nick knows what
the [ __ ] home time is his ass how to
open your pie the other day in here I
did cuz they were out of Swiss cake
rolls that's really my go to Little
Debbie I love a nice Swiss cake roll
that little thick dude could they put
more chocolate on the Swiss cake though
it's so thin yeah oh you sound like a
company man no I like I like my [ __ ]
fancy you sound like a complaint of
Potamus dawg yeah yeah and I just wanted
thicker yeah just get to man so they
ain't gonna change the whole business
model dude
I feel like I should sue Oreo cos for
the long time as a kid I should sue Oreo
Hibiscus to take up space in this dudes
hard drive lawsuits against bakeries
yeah yeah let's check this out man they
came out with mega stuff when I was a
kid I used to crack them open and then
put all the icing on the one and make a
thick ass or you'll see yeah yeah
quadruple stuff [ __ ] yeah and then
they're like Oh mega stuff they took
that [ __ ] for me idea yeah yeah I think
they get that mega stuff don't I'm fool
you with the mega I thought you wanted
more stuffing in it now you don't want
more stuff no because the mega stuff
ain't actually mega stuff do I get the
double stuffed the double stuff that
actually thicker
what's animation [ __ ] a kid with sweet
teeth knows dude that mega stuff that's
fake that's fake news I told you dude
that's fake news bro that's that Michael
Rapaport huh yeah fake news fake belt
totally raw fake news fake belt do you
know that right fake nose fake belt do
they ever have a [ __ ] McFlurry you
have to make flurry or Oreo right yeah
that's a good FFF they put some
horsepower behind that thing because we
get the spoon that thing is that spoon
because that's how they mix it look I
would love to meet you just trying to
curl up with a warm bookings a piece of
warm apple pies yeah I read a book the
other day man so nobody believed in that
huh you listen to a book Brendan is a
reading denier
first of all let's don't doubt that man
Jim what do you think about this lady
and he's these goods I know that a sugar
is a real combatant of a lot of Asian
cultures now I wanted to see kind of
what you thought no it's really me and
Nick I should have something common I'm
not a sweets person you know this right
yeah sure you know it's [ __ ]
terrorist actually this guy uses all
yeah I drink sweet stuff all the time
non Sevilla with real stevia instead of
sugar there's no sugar in there yeah
drink sweet stuff that but that's so
sweet
okay and what should we tell the lady
though you do you think Oh homemade a
hundred percent yeah homemade but
homemade he can't go sideways man has to
be just know what the [ __ ] she's doing
around that kitchen you know I'm saying
do you think she doesn't know know
operated kitchen she filmed the video in
the kitchen Brendan yeah I've seen that
pie from Costco though you know I'm
saying get that big apple pie from
Costco she ain't fooling nobody I know
my [ __ ] Swedes little let's go back
and look at that pie for a second [ __ ]
because I don't believe it I didn't like
the thing that she said you know
manufactured sweets I don't what the
[ __ ] those chocolate discs death she
brought to the screen there what was
that look at this this she's from Canada
celebration cookies bro the celebration
cook what brand is that that's a sweeter
e it's a sweeter e Brett's a local
sweeter in Canada Leclerc it looks like
yeah she Montreal or so and ban mm-hmm
that three hole puncher right there for
that freakin Marin apple pie when that
dude got caught [ __ ] the pie huh you
remember that an apple pie in American
Pie Oh American yeah yeah I loved all
three of them you did all three of them
great great sear I tried to holler at
Tara Reid one time I know how'd that go
I don't think it went a lot Terry huh
was the hot one - no she's hot for a
long time and that's kind of a little
crazy
y'all thick this is after crazy I think
ah perfect time but she had a boyfriend
or something so I didn't do it how did
you do
I didn't do anything Oh in my mind I
tried to holler you feel me that brain
holler like oh she knows what could have
happened she's in Van Wilder - hell yes
she was shooter shoe bro shooter shoot
your on sidelines dreaming about
shooting yeah but also people are trying
to the shooting ain't that safe man look
at all these people shooting at these
women out of here I did Shen's since
Sharon Stone a DM one time how long ago
was this though years ago only six
months ago Wow huh I'm here back then
you're better stone Sharon Stone's attic
instinct uh she makes headstones you
know Sharon Stone you know Sharon
Stone's Oh place she's in casino you
look up Sharon Stone's that's how you
try to holler
Jojo do her in case I don't know I would
bang her and her and uh what's that move
her Sylvester Stallone he's Rambo know
their snipers yeah oh she's in totally
good cause she's in totally she said I'm
not chicken total recall' mare when he
dreams about a girl it's her Total
Recall the specialist that [ __ ] is fire
yeah she's the white elijah douche Cobra
bring up bring her up we solve this
issue until recall Sharon Stone dude she
[ __ ] him over - but she's such a
baddie see they tried recreate Total
Recall zarnold Total Recall was good
yeah I remember when he goes out sighs
all we suffocating I remember the three
breasts run arm over a couple bullets
Ness it you don't remember when when he
puts the thing up his nose and pulls it
out the tractor of his nose huh
I don't have true lies that was a good
one
she losses okay who's about driving in
Key West and how hard it is
um alright let's see what else do we
have man that's it I want you got back
to you bro
sure in stone was your freaking lady
enough cool that be right now we'd have
around the culture corner I don't know
if we'd be that cool man she seems kind
of drastic sometimes and dressed you
know I don't think yeah I don't think it
would work out between us you ever
slighted in Madonna's dams I feel like
you have a shot with her nope mm-hmm
Sharon Stone and then probably maybe you
slice 400 strangers and that's about it
okay they're not that good nope a lot of
us from abroad Poland use your real
account you have one on fake accounts
straight up radio respect you know
Elizabeth Hurley who the skateboarder
who is it
let me get a fifty year old is she oh
you know what I think I met her actually
at a dinner one time she might be the
hottest woman alive son I know I didn't
meet her you never met her
beautiful lady though huh if she's 50
done is she on Vanderpump yeah Brendan
Fraser go back one time back one time oh
she's the devil and uh the Brendan
Fraser movie was that a bedazzled yeah
that was great
was it good I watched a movie yesterday
called gone with Amanda Seyfried and it
was bad so bad she was horrible
it's actually horrible it was about
somebody was missing and
and they she believes she'd been
kidnapped and then her sister got
kidnapped and so I'm I was bad was a bad
movie yeah it was bad man what else is
going on I'm doing the same watching
movies yeah I watch my favorite movie
like a billion times already
what's that with your boy val kilmer no
two stones on my favorite movie that's
my second angus is my first never heard
of it
angular Angus you pull up that Angus
Angus black black house Angus Angus the
animal they want earliest like teen
movies from like the 90s it sounds bad
oh it's [ __ ] great yeah but it sounds
really nice like james Van Der Beek's in
it I think this is the [ __ ] terrible
great it's got a great message well
being yourself yep Angus I watch Angus
tombstone when I'm stoned
we could watch a trailer on Angus right
here I'm swallowing snack it doesn't
taste that gross from the producer of
Cool Runnings
comes a story about fitting in she's
definitely a babe
talk to me breathless she's popular or
not there's a little joke okay watch my
butt Oh watch your hero
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the chance you've bonded your
whole life right but I can smash rich
Sanford's face in kind of temper saber
for the football field you get to dance
with Melissa Lefevre and some parts for
a chance like that it's not about your
body yeah good man go home no no no no
see if they got any more Dateline on
right we got the new cat shop you guys
can check it out we got all we got all
we got to get something for everybody
got tanks hats tea sweats hoodies some
decal sleeve featured product oh [ __ ]
baby yeah brah
you never know dawg never know man your
submission to the [ __ ] noodle Queen
look man we all got some ratchet in us
man you know got a few words for your
boy mystic Rick Oh when you droppin that
you can't drop it I think we dropped it
we'll see huh I think we dropped it
yesterday oh you dropped on Wednesday
Thursday night
yeah that was great yeah man way to go
that's how it goes bro somebody gotta
stand up to these aren't even what you
call these men leeches you know I like
to up for it it's the only way Rat King
lives bro coming out the gutter by they
got grease in the gutter dead your
trainer still uh still working or no yep
just saw the trainer this morning hell
yeah so feeling good man praise God
Chappelle's come with me to Arizona
Phoenix when y'all going next week stand
up live what they sold out though really
y'all out there there's only one wide
open the first open really yeah I might
have to get back out there I still have
one place to make up shows it yeah
Brea yeah poor breakfast man the way you
did them bro
what was his brain hurt oh it was rainin
bro
it was braining dude it was it was
raining and he wasn't feeling good so I
canceled on two hours before the show
we're always gonna have an aneurysm dude
at blood coming out of my nose brah I
was not doing well i doing well I have
Brendan's eyes in my nutsack I'm not
doing well and but doing well now though
well now bro so we'll get over there
Halla Brennan and Theo fighter and wait
I gotta go in and go hard in the paint I
do not think I am and Flo black rifle
coffee I'm ready to go
I need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this and my concerts Flo is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls leather Instagram famous damn
movie like I'm fresh off keto see a red
like Andrew Santino every Sunday is like
the great Bambino I'm 1/8 the case oh
and the case Cerritos but everything's
gonna be fine hate on me I do not mind
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
try to couldn't beat em quit playin like
Nintendo DS you don't want the smoke
like Joey Diaz meaning y'all edible just
got my eyebrows threaded and I'm feeling
an incredible grit and Sun hit me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up a sting King
and the sting bee sting Rat King
as a sting King enough steam gotta beez
in the trap got the cheese on a string
as sting King in the stink
and the sting bee sting crack
and a sting a king and a sting gonna
freeze in the track got that cheese on a
string
[Music]
gianni here waiting for the racking to
join me
racking a lot of smack being thrown
around by mr. Crick saying wrestling is
fake what are your thoughts on that was
it fake when I nabbed the gab out of
that little Russell Hunter mr. Michael
Rocco was it fake when I broke the
spirit of that little Norwegian smut
manikin mr. crystal was that fake was it
fake when I put the dirty you noggin on
little Bobby me our game was that fake
Ricky the only thing not real here is
you brother
you little diet denier starch addict
gout candidate I bet you can't even
skateboard
Rick had some choice words for the fans
of wrestling calling them losers poor
and even lowlifes
what are your thoughts on that rat Ken
you think you're better than the regular
fall creek you think you're better than
wrestling fans then the regular people
who run you out your little loose meat
dinners well I Got News for hurry what
kind of news he is saying anyone can get
it will you be the one Rat King all you
need to know Rick is that I'm ready cuz
I'm gonna give you the truth baby and
I'm gonna give you the trauma named the
time in the place in the place in the
time cuz I got a clock and a globe and
an axe to grind from Alaska to Nebraska
from Maine the Fort Wayne
it's your call you turkeys slicing
Boehner monkey you won't know what
happened when the Rat King put you in
the mozzarella splash you'll be hearing
through your feet when I put you in the
Swiss wheelchair pick your poison
you Walmart body cook cuz I'm gonna hit
her with
the glitter I'm not Hammer with the
glamour and i'ma show you how real feel
[Music]
there you have it folks the Rat King say
hello to that little side piece years to
mistake the female not the foul she
knows who I am
he means business